[Music]
welcome to Samuel Leeds podcast my name
is Alistair Cunningham and today I am
gonna be asked in Samuel Leeds himself
what he is currently buying and the
biggest mistakes he has made hey Samuel
first question I've got for you why a
useful motivated to helping people a few
reasons firstly because I think that
when you help people get what they want
selfishly you also get what you want
that's just how the world works but also
I like helping people because I think it
makes you feel good okay and in all
honesty though if the cure for feeling
sad if you ever feeling down or
depressed or miserable rather than
focusing inward about yourself and how
you feel if you think well who can I
help how can I go and help someone else
using the worse off situation than me
then well actually make you feel better
what about Ashley Ashley Bubba guy yeah
and we're training who's on our academy
Ashley was in prison and was feeling
really sorry for himself was in prison
for a few years and then he decided well
actually there's people that are in here
for life without parole and he offered
to have a bed in his cell yeah and then
he started helping people in counselling
people and then by the time he got out
of prison he was so happy you know I
agree with that and there's a lot of
negative people out there will say that
it's it's a procedure we say it's our
it's an act it's not real it's not I
know it's a genuine you because I know
you have known you for several years now
but what would you say to these people
that say that you really that's that's
not nuts not the real you I wouldn't say
anything to them because I'm not trying
to convince anybody of anything I'm just
doing my thing picking up a microphone
sharing my thoughts on a millionaire and
I did that started from scratch
people love to hear my brain and how it
happens and how to make business and
I'll just share it and if people think
people people some people might be
skeptical or what some people might
think it's some this that and the other
xanax or yo you pretending to jar I'm
not really that bothered I'm just doing
my thing and finish that's what I do
love about you to be honest that you
don't actually care what other people
any you don't care what the negative
people say about you I love that I don't
even know what the negative people say
about my yeah sometimes people say oh
you've got a bit of a bash
haven't you on on that video that you
did the other day that doesn't go down
well I don't even I don't know I don't
even read the comments I do so I do read
the comments on my videos often but like
I think you don't focus on it but some
people do a lot of people even that do
YouTube videos they make a youtube video
and it will have 100 comments and they
don't respond to any of the comments
apart from the one or two negative ones
so some will be like ah this you know
this isn't true and you're talking
nonsense and then they'll respond to
that negative comment on the opposite
for some reason I don't even see the
negative I'll just gloss over it I don't
just see the positive ones no respond
that's great I love that so you got
involved in property when you're 17
years old
yes you're now 29 28 28 what has been
the number one hardest thing you've ever
had to overcome in your property journey
probably annoying counts okay not me
annoying tenants okay annoying tennis
yeah you know that this one property
I've hated it's so bad and I've finally
sold it last night right well it was the
worst house okay what was wrong with it
there was nothing wrong with it it just
had the kiss of death on it and one way
some people have you know some people
have like bad luck yeah I think some
houses just have bad luck are they
attract bad tenants their tract problems
everything I mean I make make a couple
hundred pound a month on it but then
there's always a problem of it there's a
boiler will break and then I thought oh
man the last like six months of profit
has now gone but then six months later
something else will happen yeah okay and
it's just one of those little single at
houses up north and I've got a lot of
houses and some of my houses are just
amazing about some of my houses I've got
the same tenants in that I've been in
there like eight years yeah okay and and
and then they're like amazing the houses
are right they've got the quadrupled in
value this house guess what I bought it
seven eight years ago hmm
it's not gone up at all in value okay
it's just the same it's cost and it's
not giving me any money because any cash
flow I'm a coffee
it was spending on some repair it just
it's hot and when I sold it I told the
guy sold it jars like this house is
horrible yeah the kiss of death on it
and that's good because they everyone
talks about the glorious have probably
but to hear actually that you do have
some problems is it's good I'm sure
listeners would love that everyone's so
obviously that's that's your biggest
problem about what has been your biggest
support you say has been the biggest
success biggest lightbulb moment the
biggest thing where you're like super
proud of okay before I answer that can I
give you another big problem go on
sometimes managing your cash flow hmm
with property the biggest thing that can
go wrong is lot so you certainly have
lots of costs all at once yes and I
think when you've got just just remember
this so if you've got a few purchases go
through at the same time if you then
appoint a few boilers break and a few
this and suddenly everything comes at
once and sometimes you feel so rich a
lot oh my gosh I've got all this money
in the bank I got all this cash flood
but all this cabbage depletion
everything's going gray but if if you
don't budget and if you don't and
haven't a cash reserve in the bank it's
actually smart yeah because what
although cash in the bank is not a good
move because it should be invested and
it's shrinking in the bank just make
sure that you've got accessible funds
because refinancing houses can take
weeks if not months so yeah make sure
you've got accessible funds always for
emergencies but my biggest success the
thing that's probably what crown jewel
is the castle and yeah I only outright
it's amazing it's been really fun
restoring it yeah it mean I remember
when we first caught that you it's fair
to say that we didn't estimate enough
for the reef are busy but that was after
taking professional advice it wasn't
just you didn't just click out your
fingers and come up with a number the
Condors got okay oh you did alright okay
[Laughter]
with the castle it's impossible to know
because when you've got a building like
that there's there's underlying issues
yeah so so there's things like for
instance we didn't know that there was
bats living in the roof and there was a
special kind of bat which is still a
delayed things so much because we
couldn't do any work because we have to
protect these these wonderful bats yeah
like and some of the issues I mean you
just you just can't predict it but I
mean what what I love
about that and the way you bought that
property is there's so much cushion in
it yeah even if it does run over budget
by a million you still with me lost my
own you know what that will run over a
million that will be a million pounds
over budget yeah bet that's been but I
don't care no I'm not bothered because
the end value is so high we're gonna
make we'll make at least a million
pounds profit on that yeah we'll
probably I'll probably become a
multi-millionaire just off of that one
deal yeah and I I don't doubt that for
one minute and I'm gonna say I'm
ultimately now I mean I don't mean I'll
go from X to a multi-millionaire I mean
I'll go from you know I mean yeah you
make you make good money I know you're
gonna make a lot a lot yeah I know you
and is so so such a so satisfying the
history of even I've even the Free
French soldiers have flown down from
France that I think there's only a few
they're still alive today the guy that
came down he was in his 90s and he came
now with his grandchild and some
different folks and took us out for a
beautiful lunch in Mayfair London and
then flew back to France and and that
the the people that we've got to know
through the castle and also the the news
stories and the media and yeah it's just
so satisfying to be amazing when it's
done if they come back over and that it
was see you they're gonna come see them
so he's telling me to hurry up because
he's obviously very old he said I don't
want to die until you've finished
restoring that castle so but the thing
is I am happy for the cows to take a
while I think we've brexit it would be a
very bad time because when that castle
finishes I want to sell it yeah okay not
the whole thing but I'll sell off some
of the apartments yeah and it'll be very
bad timing to sell apartments in like
not now yeah terrible time so I'm
playing my cards very carefully and
people won't realize how genius I am in
2019 or even in 2020 mm go on into the
2000s people will look back and they'll
realize how genius I am because yeah
because of how I'm playing my cards
right now if some of these deals that
I'm doing because when I when it comes
when the time comes for me to want to
sell some of these apartments are in the
castle it'll be the right time yeah and
the castle will finish at the right time
and it the budget will be right and
everything will be right
my cell phone it's wait work sort
yourself out I'll sort it out yeah but
it will it will be very good and also
not only the
but I just think I'm gonna live there
man honestly serious I think I'm gonna
we should have a show home that the
target is to have in the summer is to
have a show home yeah and the castle
okay and I think I'll probably move in
that's my plan right okay so forgetting
property obviously you're on trainer
business you run the bit we run the
biggest training business in europe with
the highest success rate obviously
you've had a lot of success students
come through I am being one of them why
is that so important to you like
obviously we come through the training
program I've been really successful
there's been lots of our successful
students what motivates you to keep
going and because I know the target
issues 108 I don't know if we're gonna
hit that annoyingly okay annoying last
year 54 people became financially free
as a result of our training and I wanted
this year to double that and do 108 I
think where I think we just shy of 90
okay so I've got a few months left a few
months left we've got like next month is
the last month of the year six weeks
what I'm hoping what I'm hoping for
though is there's a lot of people that
are almost financially for a yeah so I
haven't got to make like a hundred and
sorry 100 and I've got another to say 15
people to make financially from scratch
yeah it's a lot of people that are
always there I wish I could just pull
them over the line I might do that yeah
on Christmas Day
I might just go around people's houses
who are almost financially free of my
training but not quite financially free
go around the house on Christmas Day and
just get that Nick's deal over the line
yeah and then me as them and then and
then and then I'll be able to get my
hundred and eight this year you talked a
lot about financial freedom you talk a
lot about how you're financially free
from property and that's what that's
what everyone's goal is a lot of people
would argue that running a training
business is not financial freedom so
there's got to be a bigger picture
what's the bigger picture for you
because it is hard what run you you know
this I must run define business is hard
work my training business it doesn't
make any financial my financial freedom
is for my properties my training
business is a something that I do from a
mission or point of view does it make
money absolutely
but any profits that we make goes back
into the business
yeah it pays wages and we left over
we'll invest into property so then let's
talk about your mission then if you've
seen it's about mission which I know it
is about mission yeah what is the what
is the bigger picture for you so from a
selfish point of view I guess I could I
could talk about it as a very you know
very noble thing how could all these
people leave their jobs and become
financially free rich and there is a
good intent on it but from a selfish
point of view I think it just gives me
real significance I think there's a
quote I think from John Maxwell he says
success is great but once you've tasted
significance success loses its sweetness
okay I don't think it's quite how how we
worded it in fact I think I was at it
better I should rephrase the quote but
it's yeah it's really true I mean I do
get really excited when I make money in
property I do you get really excited
from do it doing a deal but in all
seriousness hands on heart there's
nothing more that gives me a sense of
significance and makes me feel proud and
happy then when people message me and
say hey Samuel my wife has just quit her
work yeah because of your training and
she was working as a nurse really bad
back and and now she's afraid she's
gonna be able to spend more time with
the kids and it's made our lives better
like for my selfish point of view that
makes me feel really good and also from
a selfish point of view the positioning
that I get from being from running the
largest property training company in the
UK like just being able to speak in
front of thousands of thousands of
people being able to reach millions of
people on YouTube and across the social
media platforms it means that if ever I
want to do a deal if ever I want to do a
joint venture yeah I can I can easily do
that also I get to meet cool people I
get to hang out with celebrities and be
me and I wouldn't be if I was just
making loads of money in property
celebrities wouldn't want to meet me but
because I'm making loads of money in
property but also I'm giving back and
I'm helping others do the same and and
I'm doing YouTube videos and help him
put myself out there it just means that
I'm more influential and people want to
be with know there's a lot of people
making a lot of money in property but
there's not got their brand and in the
position in behind like you have yeah
and that's amazing that brings a lot of
opportunities now obviously financial
freedom like you could literally stop
today you could literally pull the plug
and everything to the eagle and sit in a
beach why don't you do that because
there's absolutely nothing more boring
and mind-numbing
than lying on a beach I mean I I do like
to Lana Beach for maybe a few hours
maybe even a few days maybe but a few
weeks a few months a lifetime it would
just be torture
I mean retiring and and and and then
doing nothing I just and I actually
think that I didn't know that I'd be the
case when I first got into property I
just wanted to be financially free and
also thinking that way about just travel
yes I'll be able to do some charity work
but I didn't think that when I became
financially free I'll be so gripped and
obsessed with wanting to to run a
training business wanting to grow and do
bigger deals go on to buy development
projects hire people speak all over the
world run events I don't think that
would be the case but I just gives me a
buzz so this this they're going to today
then what you actually buying out the
minute what deals have we got going to
it the minute what what you're buying at
the minute um so properties that we're
looking at the moment they were putting
offers on was a piece of piece of land
in Leeds which which I've just been
looking over at the moment which is two
hundred thousand pounds that I'm really
quite excited about build build some
maybe you know I think it's an apartment
block we're looking to build on there
but that hasn't actually gone through
all we haven't even had an offer
accepted yet I mean we've we're just in
the process of building six houses from
scratch at the moment in Lincoln yeah
which is going pretty well so we bought
that land maybe four months ago we've
done a YouTube video about this one but
yeah I tend to see videos about
everything to be honest so that's going
well I think we should be selling those
six houses we've done it a joint venture
with someone so they'll be getting -
I'll be getting four houses and that
should be doing the next few months
castle obviously that's that's that's
like mega and obviously you doing bigger
stuff now and but the little stuff as
well yeah I was gonna say these little
houses still interest you like no I'm
not talking about a lot of 40 grand
houses and
me too and a month but like hate your
moles things that your bread and butter
cause HMOs was your bread and butter
that's where you yeah that's what you
were known as the HM also most of my
portfolio is small residential houses
okay it's single let's up north its HMOs
in Birmingham and Wolverhampton and it's
apartments and that that is the majority
do you do you know how many houses you
actually own I know you don't deal with
it you've got management deal with it
but I've got just over fifty fifty
houses I guess it depends you could make
it sound more because technically like
the castle is a lot of houses there is
though this castles like I think we've
got we've got 12 apartments four houses
and then so sometimes people ask me you
know how many houses doing well the
thing is I like just yesterday I sold a
house yeah and I'm part of my strategy
is buy and sell and I do joint ventures
so it's not about how many houses you've
got it's more about what's your net
worth
yeah okay this forget property for a
while let's talk about you as a person
what is a typical day in the life of
some of these look like varies every
day's different to me one day
all right someday Oh someday I just
family night so he spent even man than
the kids yeah good okay Sunday go to
church then have a nice most dinner
maybe have some friends over some family
over and then and then watch watch a
movie you know and if you had to if you
had to like forget everything just to
chill out just to have your time with
just you what what's the ideal thing you
would do to be almost on most energized
when I'm working yeah and when I meet
people
so today I've been I just had a meeting
we've we've I don't like actually say
who it is we've both better meet with
some very very famous we're looking to
do some stuff with some very very high
profile net worth individuals so that
was really cool a couple hours
brainstorming trying to help them with
that with their property plan doing
podcast then I'm going down to I've got
a meeting with the solicitors after this
to talk about updating some of our
contracts and then tonight I'm driving
to Droitwich yeah and then two more
training so we are on the way to
Droitwich tonight for the last ever deal
friend an extravaganza well yeah the
last one
morning and the last ever never use your
money again progress yeah for sure first
biggest ever biggest ever biggest ever
that's never yeah you see we might get a
couple hundred people and their enemy
cap out we've got like a massive venue
if we've literally solved the whole
thing I think we've got four hundred
people for yeah 400 450 and it's gonna
be it's gonna be insane I think as well
at the those advanced training programs
people tend to get deals are very fast
and make money and make things happen so
if there's 400 people there and it's an
advanced training program that's that
should be able to hunt with my hundred
mate mission yeah absolutely I bet
there's some of those guys in the room
out those 400 a bet there's some of them
they're financially free already because
of my training and I don't even know it
that's the problem keeping up I went to
an auction I went to a London auction a
couple weeks ago I was actually asked to
come and present the or open up the
auction and some people come up to me
left right and centre at the auction
it wasn't advertised as far as I was
aware that I was gonna be there so it
wasn't like it was my er then everyone
knew me and everyone was saying not
everyone I had had about five people
that said that they got into property
because of my videos yeah and there was
two guys who are full-time in property
financially free and they got started
because of me in my videos and I came to
my crash course like three years ago so
I'm like 909 figure this year I bet
we've already smashed that it's almost
impossible to track every week I'll
bring someone on the winners Wednesday
and I interview them but and then and
then we na and we have messages and we
can we track you know just just with
Italia bout how and people will help
become financially free but I honestly
believe next year I just think it's
gonna be impossible to track mmm maybe I
should keep track what do you think you
think I should keep tracking or do you
think we should just say you know what
the thing is the amount of people that
it's coming through the system and and
been really successful is this but it's
difficult to keep track
we do have client performance team
downstairs they do keep track of a lot
of stuff but yeah it's good to get them
on their own the winners in a way and
sometimes people become financially free
and then they don't want to come on when
is Wednesday because they they don't
want to like put themselves out there
because they're they're scared that
their family will start asking for money
or they don't want their that their
financially free with their in a
corporate job and and they just don't
want their bosses to know
not actually left work yet and they want
to leave work or maybe they are scared
of camera that camera shy yeah all
they're worried about how they'll be
perceived so every person that comes on
when is Wednesday respect man because I
know it takes a lot of courage to come
on the show but you know what you'll
find is when you come on when is
Wednesday and I bet you found this what
happened what happened when you came on
you just get really your brand just goes
bang I mean I come on winners I was a
third person on winners in a Wednesday
yeah so I've not been on winners of
Wednesday for a long long time and and
you get messages from all over the world
you get people messing you say I won't
do business we I want to JV we you can
you help me do this young me do that and
then what happens is you become more
successful and then suddenly you go from
financially for you to ultimately
financially for your rich yeah I've seen
it's happened so many times now think
about this right we've just run a
program last week called tell the world
and we had Ashley barber I was on there
yeah really nice guy really
inspirational guy you you hear a story
he's come through the training program
and he's going to you're going to teach
him to speak on the stages and to train
from stages what do you see his end goal
being like people come through the
training programs like the train tell
the world things are yeah where do you
see them being in three four years time
okay so start from the beginning when
people first decide they wanna get into
property or they want to become
financially free or they want to be
successful the one over in a business
whatever I think that sometimes they
want to do it because they want to go
and spend more time at home yeah
sometimes they want to do it because
they want to be able to just be the best
version of themselves or they want to
travel or they want to do but sometimes
I really feel that some people want to
do it because you want to speak yeah
they want to become successful because
they then want the authority not in a
bad way but they want the they want to
be able to earn the right themselves
because really they have a deep desire
to help other people and it might be
their kids they might want to apply I
want my kids to be successful and happy
well before my kids are successful happy
all become successful and happy all
become financially free I'll become a
great business person or whatever and
then I want to teach my kids and then
I'm gonna teach other people so I think
we've actually Bubba the guy you're
talking about clearly he's a guy who
only really wants to become so
successful in business and property I
think because
he has such a desire and a fire in his
belly to share his story and he wants to
tell more people which i think is
awesome so I don't know what actually
bubbles futures I mean the guys that
come on tell the world last week I mean
there was only six people there yeah
very very intimate program but I think
you killed it by the way and I've run
some of the training as well but they're
gonna be they're gonna be awesome
they are gonna be absolutely phenomenal
I mean there was Anthony and James
Callum Ricky Ashley I know well we're
gonna put them all on our stages and
they have to do a good job they might
end up being there might end up being
business owners there might not being
mentors themselves or trainers I don't
know but the future's bright no
obviously we were on a training business
we were advocates for educating self
education and I know you've spent a
large sum of money on your own education
yeah there must be in some times you've
invested and it's not being worth it and
there's must been times when you've what
see you what would you say was the
biggest and the biggest return on
investment for a training program yard I
have never invested and regret it never
cool because even though other columns
and they've not been good hmm there's
always been something that I've learned
or someone that I met which is paid back
for the training I love iron never avoid
it and now I've been on some really
really really crappy programs you get
out what you put in with anything yeah
you could say to me Samuel could you pay
could could you pay me a thousand pounds
and and and I'm just gonna I'm just
gonna be a sounding board for your own
thoughts I never get a good return on
investment yeah so you know now that's
not to say that the programs were good
I've been on some really rubbish
programs but the best program that I've
been on it's really hard it's really
hard for me to say the best training
program I mean I think man I'll have to
get back to you on that one I don't know
what the best ones been okay I've been
on so many I mean Regent now I've just
I've just spent two hundred thousand
pounds with Grant Cardone which which
which might just more one-on-one session
with him I had once it had one session
with him I was like I'll make that money
back from this session yeah I love the
wee
look at this the way you look at the
it's an investment and a lot of people
look at paying for education courses as
a cost it's not as an investment
yourself yeah and what you said about
how you get out of it what you put in is
very very true there's even it might be
Effie my original DfE when it was like
30 people in there there's there's a
I've gone on to there was four or five
of us went on to do really really well
and other people didn't maybe didn't
implement as much as issuing you if I
remember rightly when you went to the
deal finding extravaganza like a couple
years back or so I was running the
training yeah and you were partnered
with a woman mm-hm and the woman was a
bit of a negative load a para negative
yeah and she was like ah it seems a bit
to be sure that love her like there so
she was basically just bitching about
life in the universe you she didn't
particularly like me either
and then she went on to do nothing and
now she's still doing the same thing I
imagine yeah probably the same financial
situation I imagine a copy hundred
percent yeah she's definitely not going
to do anything amazing and you were
making 40,000 pound a month see property
yeah so ultimately when you go on a
training program it just shows it's
about the implementation yeah rather
than about the trainer I mean when
people come on my training programs they
get results believe me they get results
but I can only I can only give them so
much ultimately they need to take action
be responsible for themselves
yeah for sure I mean I like go on a
training program I never like I'm not
gonna go meet Grant Cardone and pay him
200 grand and they go right make me make
me richer no he's not gonna do anything
what I'm gonna say is I'm gonna come
with good questions and I'm gonna say
can you help me yeah here's where I'm
struggling what's your advice and then
he's gonna tell me what I should do and
he's gonna give me ideas he's gonna give
me inspiration and and then I and then
gonna go and implement and make it
happen so it's a two-way it's a two-way
think yeah 100% hundred percent so this
weekend we're going to DfE your friend
extravaganza last one everyone have is
there anything you got in your pocket to
replace the DfE next for the deal five
minutes right did not depend if any
extravaganzas going to continue but
you're not running it but never use your
money again program you know what I
think I just want to focus a little bit
more on some of the really advanced you
so some of our people in our Academy
that are doing you know really heavily
investing into themselves so I'm gonna
be focusing on the accelerated coaching
and mentoring program where I'm gonna be
giving ya and you know sort of bespoke
kind of you know literally people
obviously and watch your situation what
can I help you with yeah where you're at
and going around the room just really
giving people that kind of more intimate
support that's gonna be cool I want to
focus more on people that are a bit more
a bit more serious and then with the
with the crash courses I'm stepping back
a little bit yeah you know you're
running some of the crash course is Ryan
Grider's willing some of the crash
courses I love doing the crash courses
I'll still run them but the demand for
them is so great yeah I can't if I
commit doing every single crash course
myself then I wouldn't really have much
of a life no outside of being a trainer
yes I still want the training to happen
and that's why I'm so grateful and glad
that we've got people like you who have
got the same knowledge I've got now yeah
and also able to communicate yeah
they're still going through the same
training well I never thought two years
ago I'd be doing this I never thought
I'd be able to speak on stage in front
of a thousand people comfortably and and
authority so yeah it's really really
good confidence confidence comes from
knowledge yeah you have if you know what
you're talking about yeah you don't need
to be nervous yeah
so you're knowledgeable you don't need
to be nervous so what do you think the
move to London officer we've moved
offices London we're now all London
bound what do we or we're now in London
not London man we're here what do you
think are you happy with the movie
please that happens I love living in I
don't well technically I live just
outside London I live in Buckinghamshire
offices are in London I think I might
rent an apartment in London so I've kind
of got to play like a little pad in
London work and sleep over in the week
sometimes and then when I want to just
really relax go back to my main the
Samuel Leeds mansion yeah it's nice
right the London lifestyle is and all
the others the best thing in the world
is absolutely just is I mean and people
so I put that on Facebook and I got a
little height no it's not you know
you're an idiot listen man it's a very
subjective thing yes and I've not been
to every city in the world but I've been
to many cities and London's
my personal favorite I love the people I
love the vibe I love the weather yeah I
like it cold when it's cold you can work
better yeah when it's hot all the time
man I was in Miami and I was just
thinking but when I was with gran and I
was thinking how does Grant Cardone and
just live and work here all the time I
don't get it I love it being cold I love
the seasons I love how fast-paced it is
I love the shops I love the buildings
I love the cleanliness I love I just
love London yeah I agree I look at
people I love the opportunities I love
the investment opportunities I love the
properties ah it's a great place to live
before we get wrapped up couple more
questions if there's anything you could
I know you don't I know you don't live
with regrets in example there's anything
you could have done differently over the
last 10 years what would have been if
there was like her what I'm trying to
get out is if those are a point in your
career where you had a decision to make
we went left or right and you chose left
but perhaps it wasn't right what would
that yeah you know honestly say I
wouldn't do anything different okay I
know that sounds like come on you must
be doing something different even the
bad things I could say I wouldn't have
got on that boat Yeah right
but even when I got on that boat and
broke my leg you were on the boat it
wasn't a pleasant experience look at the
goodness come out of that look at the
stuff as a resort that I went to I was
in hospital in Uganda the connections
that I made in that hospital with the
doctors and some of the stuff now that
we're doing and how we're helping with
other patients that can't afford
surgeries as it resolved me be in there
now so could I say oh if I went back I
wouldn't get in the boat well I haven't
got in the boat everything that's
happened in my life has led to me being
right here with you having this
conversation so I wouldn't take anything
back I know that's amazing
bad things have happened have just been
lessons and the good things that have
happened have been awesome I love the
fact you see the bad things have been
lessons not failures because they're not
favorites the only the only feels if you
stop well a lot of factor we've drawn
lessons from them and right okay so
let's get wrapped up and people are
looking to get in probably invest in
part from coming to the crash course
what is that your top tips for something
that's brand new wanting to get involved
in property doesn't have a massive pot
of money to invest maybe ten thousand
pound and they want to get involved in
property what would you say they need to
do what was their action steps for these
guys make friends with other people are
doing you know if you're on your own
feels like hard yes but if I was if I
didn't know any other business owners
and any other property investors how
could I physically get up and just do it
and it weird so I think find other
people that doing it take massive action
be a be unafraid you know you've got a
you gotta be prepared to step out there
and if you your your mind in your brain
is designed to keep you comfortable yeah
and that's what everyone wants to be
comfortable but in order to be a
successful property investor you've got
to become uncomfortable yeah as I always
say get comfortable being uncomfortable
so just just don't go and view houses go
to an auction talk to agents tell them
what you're looking for make a business
plan run it past a property accountant
but you know just be a little bit
unafraid but at the same time of course
educate yourself and make sure before
you actually put money down on
properties and before you make big
decisions just make sure you've got a
good knowledge because as I always say
property is the second best investment
the best is yourself yeah I agree with
you so on that bombshell guys thank you
very much for tuning in samu have been
amazing as always thank you for a loan
me to interview and who you guys thank
you very much
[Music]
[Music]
you
[Music]